william grider author of secrets of the
temple your book is subtitled how the
Federal Reserve runs the country have we
been wrong to think it was the
politicians all along at least half
wrong yes strange as a team the without
going into all the esoterica of what the
Federal Reserve the central bank
actually does in the largest frame it
regulates money and interest rates and
that is a is one of the most immediate
and powerful influences if the
government has over the real economy
workers producers stores etc simply by
manipulating the price of money which
inevitably changes the price of almost
every other transaction and it's
insulated from the politicians quite
deliberately so yes your the notes on
the book Jack of congested in some ways
the Federal Reserve is quoting the
jacket now is more secretive than the
CIA and more powerful than the President
and Congress that really sounds sounds
grandiose i know but i think that's
right i thought about that a long time
and then it is like the CIA in many ways
in that it's run by a community of
experts technocrats who have skills and
knowledge which are not generally
available if secrecy is is even greater
than the CIA's in the sense that the CIA
at least has to go to the Congress on a
fairly regular basis share its plans
with the Congress albeit in secret
meetings of the Intelligence Committee
get an annual appropriation which is a
powerful lever with Congress doesn't
like what the CIA is doing in Nicaragua
it says thou shalt not spend money for
this the Federal Reserve has none of
those controls the Federal Reserve is
required to testify regularly before
Congress but it is not required to
reveal its secret deliberate
deliberations or even its it's real
expectations for what's going to happen
in the economy and more importantly it
makes its own budget
not submit to the appropriations process
that every other agency of government
must submit to and the Federal Reserve
well understands that's real power and
real protection from from both
presidents and Congress is that that
power something that evolved or was it
given that power from day one yeah I
think it well it did evolve and I and
you know who knows but it survived for
75 years without any really fundamental
reforms that that took away is its
independence on the other hand it's hard
to believe that if he created this
animal today and submitted it to
Congress that they would approve it in
its present form what happened is that
it was created back in 1913 with what
people believed at the time were fairly
limited and mechanical functions there
was rigidities in the money supply which
produced periodic catastrophes and the
idea was to create a more flexible
system that would that could feed in
into the money supply periodically to to
just become more elastic was the phrase
they used at that time what the Fed
discovered quite haltingly over a period
of two decades was that the power to do
that was really the power to manipulate
the whole economy and that is to
stimulate or restrain and that its
actions fed directly in the interest
rates in financial markets all over the
place and from financial markets into
the transactions of labor business
consumers and so forth that wasn't
instant knowledge on anybody's part and
as they grasped that nobody had
sufficient cause to say or wait a minute
that ought to be done by somebody else
or it ought to be done in a more
democratic manner and in addition I
think both political parties understood
that this is really the fulcrum between
debtors and creditors between the people
with a lot of wealth and the p
none between labor and capital it's a
very deep political transaction that
goes on in this management of money and
so the compromise which was struck in
1913 held over the over many years oh
and there have been many fluctuations in
that but basically no one since and then
the Fed has had critics on both sides
liberal conservative Republican
Democratic but no one since has ever
been able to put together a powerful
enough coalition to undo it another
quote from your book you say a Federal
Reserve System was the crucial anomaly
at the very core of representative
democracy why wife was it an anomaly and
why has it become so crucial well it's
anomaly it's an anomaly because our
civic mythology tells us that people are
sovereign that the people ultimately
choose their representatives and that
those representatives must be
accountable in regular times that's why
we have elections every two years for
the federal government every four years
for the president the Federal Reserve is
exempt from that process and yet it has
enormous political power those who
believe the mythology would say oh well
that's not quite right because this is
just a technical function it's not
politics well when I i mean i think
that's rubbish because its political in
the sense that here is an agency making
very large public choices for us that
will reward some interests and damage
other interests that may not be their
motive in doing it but that's the result
that's that's political in the deepest
meaning of the word and when when you go
behind the economics of the Fed and and
look at what you know which choices they
make whether you agree with them and
disagree with them what you really under
what you really come to see is that
these are choices of values poker has a
certain set of values which he brought
the government and and imposed quite
successfully and you can argue that the
country on the whole supported those
values
but the people who were damaged the
victims from both the deep recession and
from from the bani money policy that
followed have no access to express their
grievances there's no recourse and they
could they can write angry letters to
the Fed which they do or they could call
our congressman and a congressman is
likely to tell them well yes isn't the
Fed terrible but we can't do anything
about it and and all I'm suggesting is
that this there's something wrong in the
system that's that's sequestered with
that much power then I would just add in
passing the word anomaly stops people
and I first heard that used by a former
president of a federal reserve bank they
understand that perfectly they did that
it's an anomalous situation they defend
it for lots of different reasons you
mentioned Paul Volcker in your book
focuses on him quite a bit in your book
you say that his appointment was the
most important appointment of Jimmy
Carter's presidency and you have a line
of the Paul Volcker would go on to seize
control of event and force them in a
direction of his own choosing I was one
person able to do that well the
institution the Federal Reserve but he
he provided the leadership and what
happened in very simple terms was an
inflation in the summer 1979 was running
well into double digits of there was a
lot of sort of runaway speculative
buying real estate gold was going toward
eight hundred and fifty dollars an ounce
and the Carter Administration was deep
in its own political problems including
a kind of sense of confusion about what
to do about it in this Carter appoints
Volcker in July August of 79 two months
later despite objections and and pleas
from the White House he imposes in
october six nineteen seventy-nine a new
monetarist regime that the Fed which
which is without going into the
complications basically said we're going
to hold the money supply at a steady
stream level regardless of what happens
to
interest rates knowing of course that
interest rates would go through the roof
and also really regardless of what
happens to the real economy and that's
power and and Carter was in such a weak
in position at that point in his
presidency that even though they didn't
like it at the White House they could
not object and it was a very subtle
political transaction but everybody
involved knew what was happening he book
starts in the late 70s but it gets into
the 80s during the Reagan administration
and President Reagan came in on a large
wave of popularity and yet the bug goes
on to say that the awkward political
secret of the 80s is that while the
public blamed Reagan it was Volcker who
was actually running the economy even
President Reagan was was unable to
affect said policy yeah and the two
elements to that Volkers objective which
is to hold things down including
presumably a recession until this upward
curve of inflation is broken he is he is
in the midst of that without having made
much progress when Ronald Reagan comes
to office and Ronald Reagan introduces
an alluring but contradictory idea of
how this can be done he says we will
stimulate the economy with these huge
tax cuts increased defense spending so
forth and that's going to make everybody
robust and healthy again at the very
time we urge the Federal Reserve to go
further do exactly what Paul Volcker
wants to do which is to tighten money
and you don't have to be an economist to
understand that there's something wrong
in that formulation how do you get go up
with an economy at the very time you're
holding it down and that's set up a
collision between the Fed and the rest
of government that is endured to this
day and it literally is a collision of
purposes and I call it a phrase I
borrowed from a fed economist it's a
game of chicken between the two sides of
government and invoker really won that
game with isaac disastrous consequences
but i mean you're at least severe damage
but in any case as a matter of will as a
matter of political strength and
fortitude and skill he won that and and
when you got past the recession of
1981-82 then the White House
particularly looking forward to the 1984
election changes its its outlook
dramatically and says for god sakes get
out of the way with the type money lets
us let this economy roar and that's when
that's when Volcker and Reagan are
really in very direct conflict it's
played out in sort of a bleak public
terms so that there's it's not the sort
of argument in battle that you see in
Congress where the White House is one
thing and the house speaker says
something contrary that and you you have
a public argument these are these are
much more subtle and you have to really
know the language of this course before
you can follow the outline of the
argument but it's a very serious
argument and and basically vulgar one
this collision you talk about is that's
only based on the personalities involved
or is this going to be institutionalized
with us for years to come well I think
its institutionalized and I and I hope
this is what people get out of my book
it's not about was Paul Volcker a good
guy or a bad guy or even whether Ronald
Reagan was smart or dumb or whether his
policies made any sense it it's like
what I saw in my long study of this this
whole area is that we have this we have
the government designed in a way that
guarantees this collision one way or
another and what it produces is not
stability which was the original idea
you know that we'd have this balance
where the Fed gets strict and holds two
things back Congress and the president
are the boomers and they want to go
forward and so these two would sort of
balance out that isn't what happens what
happens in real history is that one side
gets control and goes to an extreme then
the other side gets control and it goes
to an extreme if you think back over the
last 25 years that's what's happening
are
government first we had this sort of
Congress and a series of presidents not
just Lyndon Johnson but a number of his
successors who really want to do more
than they can pay for and so forth and
so on and we'll fight wars or whatever
and that produces a decade or more of
runaway inflation then the Fed finally
gets control and once they're on top
they won't let go and instead of going
for a more gradual balanced amelioration
of inflation they drive things really
hard really down hard and and that has
consequences which we are still faced
with I mean starts in Iowa if you put in
the most obvious sense but it's also
Mexico which is deep trouble and a lot
of corporations that are in deep trouble
not to mention consumers but the my
argument in the book is that you've got
to find some mechanism to marry those
two policies fiscal policy and monetary
policy that it is that it is insane for
the federal government to try to manage
the economy with these two independent
power centers that don't have to talk to
each other even in any real sense and
when I say that I'm fully aware that
that's a that's another way of saying
you have to you have to eliminate the
Independence of the Federal Reserve
following that up you relate an exchange
of the hearing in your book between
senator byrd and mr. bolter where
senator byrd ask the question something
to the effect of who are you responsible
to mr. Volker responds single Congress
created us you could uncreate it if
Congress doesn't like what the feds
doing can't they do something about it
sure that wise and broker who is a very
astute politician said that with it with
a little little curl in his in his words
because he knows perfectly well that
Senator Byrd does not have the political
power to sell that to Congress and the
one one of the things that played out
through the 80s was a struggle of who of
who really is going to discipline whom
and in that sense Congress could wipe
out the Fed tomorrow on but you've got
to put together a broad enough coalition
that wants to do that and I think unless
something very dramatic and buying on
happen to our society I think that's not
likely we're talking with William Grider
he's author of secrets of the temple how
the Federal Reserve really runs our
country the title secrets of the temple
where does that come from well it's an
allusion to a theme a sub-theme that I
have throughout the book which used that
money and for that matter economics has
religious properties that are both moral
and also metaphysical in a way it's not
it's not simply quaint and accidental
that money was first coined in the
temples of all the classical
civilizations and the Fed even though it
is a very highly rationalistic
institution with lots of mathematical
equations and economists and so forth
what one would think is the opposite of
religious actually cloaks itself in much
of the same style and and thought
processes I mean it runs through just a
couple of them with the mystique of the
central bank is it phrased that that's
used even by fed people quite
unconsciously what that suggests is so
there's some mystery going on here and
secondly on the federal reserve board
though it does it in a prosaic way has
the same role of ancient temple priests
which is that is a prophetic leader that
says this is how we think the future
looks this is what we think will happen
to the economy and and that's that's a
kind of prophecy making that that that
the Fed does justice as ancient temple
spit and finally money itself has a very
complex and an almost frightening bundle
of psychological spiritual means
you had tucked it talk to somebody who
wants the gold standard restored and
chances are they will say the gold is is
just as a version of God's money that's
the way God intended it to me and you
sort of think what is it one how did God
get into this well God has always been
very close to money with as secretive
and mysterious as you said that that is
was it easy to get people to talk about
it was easy to find the information you
needed to write this book yeah I think I
mean easy it's those five years of hard
work but but in terms of the shoe mean
they were fairly cooperative what I what
I did discover I spent a lot of time and
the heart of my reporting was
interviewing Federal Reserve Board
governors presidents of the 12 Federal
Reserve banks and the Chairman I found
them pre straightforward they didn't
tell me their deepest secrets but they
but they answered my questions in a very
straightforward way I found this to the
Fed staff with some notable exceptions
but particularly here in Washington much
more reluctant to be sort of open and
straightforward about what was going on
secrets of the temple your most recent
effort also national editor at rolling
stone for the past five years author of
the book the education of david stockman
and others that was published by EF
Hutton based on an article in Atlantic
Monthly former assistant managing editor
of The Washington Post was with the post
for 14 years as a reporter and editor
and also the Washington bureau of the
Louisville courier-journal cover
politics for Rolling Stone written the
books have a preference well I have I
think probably what's the ideal life
where I get to do both I mean I hope I
get to do both I'm I'm an old newspaper
reporter and the idea of simply only
doing books would I think drive me nuts
you want to be in print you want to be
closer to events in that and in doing
the column for rolling stone gives me
a really interesting broad national
audience that's quite different from a
Washington items like the one I had at
the post so it's a nice next you talk
about the news media in the book and you
say about their coverage of the Fed you
say the news media rarely paid much
attention to what was said by the
Federal Reserve governors and if one
judge at the central bank is solely on
the basis of its uncritical press
coverage the Federal Reserve appeared to
be the only agency of government that
never made mistakes the media's job of
covering the Fed not so good yeah I
think so I'm sure there are a lot of
financial reporters who will be offended
by that but in part of what I need is
that they don't they don't make much of
an effort to really speak to the broader
audience of citizens about Fed policy p
read The Wall Street Journal which is
whose coverage is the best of all for
obvious reasons it has it has excellent
daily coverage of monetary policy you
can follow the arguments and so forth
but it even even the journal only makes
periodic attempts to say hey wait a
minute this isn't much broader story
than whether m1 is up or down whether
the federal funds rate is rising or
falling and so forth just that one
example of the speeches one of the
things I did it was quite tedious but
I've got virtually every speech that all
of these governors had made and most of
those speeches are made to your academic
audiences or financial groups or the
business assemblies one kind another and
it's true they are written in the sort
of dense and opaque language of Comus
clouded with euphemisms so forth and so
on but if you read them through very
patiently and particularly read them in
series what if this guy say six months
ago and what is he saying now it's very
helpful and very informative so I would
think the very least newspapers ought to
do is start covering those speeches more
more effectively we've talked here today
about Paul Volcker but in your book you
also talked about the other governors
and without listing them by name they're
intelligent generally who are these
people what are their background well
qualification you know that they're from
the very beginning that then he's
wonderfully rich and sometimes quite
ugly conspiracy theories surrounding the
Federal Reserve is this power center
that runs the world or that's part of
the conspiracy for world dominion that
goes back to the Illuminati etc etc when
you look at the people who are Federal
Reserve Board governor's what you
discover is that most of them with one
or two exceptions have come from
somewhere in the Midwest that went to a
big Midwestern university their father
was may have been a mailman or a plumber
or an electrician or a YMCA secretary I
mean it's a wonderful sort of American
thing it seems to me that if you're
smart if you work hard and if you get
you know you have to you have to punch
the right tickets and so forth but yes
you can rise to a quite powerful
position and you don't have to come from
a wealthy banker family to get on the
Federal Reserve Board quite the contrary
your book wraps up with the so-called
Black Monday last October with the state
stock market decline you attribute that
directly to the policies of Paul Volcker
and fed well I think people will be
arguing over this for the rest of our
lives probably but i think if you say
that the stock market crash was was
essentially a symptom of the deeper
disorders that we are now confronted
with which is I think the right way to
look at it and then you ask are like
what was a triggering event that that
that produced this shock and and
collapse of faith then I think the
Federal Reserve is a leading candidate
yes because it sounds too melodramatic
to be true but in fact it is true that
the Federal Reserve in the last two or
three years created the same pattern of
control over money that led to the crash
of 1929 and without going into the to
the complications of it two years ago
they let the money supply
enormously probably because they had no
choice unless they wanted to force a
recession which of course they didn't
want to do at 1985 I don't question
their judgment about that but money
supply flows balloons not much is
happening in the real economy of work in
production so it flows into financial
speculation that's the beginning of this
really wild run up at Wall Street
particularly in the stock market then in
1986 the Fed tried to take some of that
liquidity out of the economy out of the
financial system and money supply was
held down in September having held money
growth very low it raised the discount
rate for the first time in three years
at the very time the stock market was
trying to go up again and the real
economy was coming back reviving those
two things put pressure on the total
liquidity in the in the economy people
need more money transactions your rising
prices are rising blah blah blah so
they're pulling back at that same time
and it's like a it's like a traumatic
effect on the stock market and there a
number of a student market analyst who
that's exactly their diagnosis of what
happened nobody in politics much less
the Federal Reserve Board has yet
addressed that which I find fascinating
it there I think if we have a
congressional hearing six months or a
year two years from now which is what
happened after 1929 that's going to be
one of the leading theories about what
happened the book looks back at the past
eight years in an amazing detail in the
several minutes that we have left let's
look ahead what would your
recommendations be to administration to
the Fed to keep some of those problems
from happening again and what do you
think will happen down the road well I
think I think we're in serious we're in
grave economic crisis right now and the
first problem the first danger is to
avoid a recession and I think people
have an idea that well you have a
recession then you have another
recession
there's so many weakened debtors around
not just our economy but the world
particularly those LDC countries with
all that debt but if the u.s. goes into
a recession now it could get out of
control I don't know that it will get
out of control I can't say that with
with but I think it's a risk we ought
not to take so that's the first thing
then I think there's a much more general
reconstruction which is going to take
many years and and most people know all
of the elements of that of the debts the
federal debt and the death of trade
deficits and so forth I would add a
couple of others one is one is the
malice tribution of incomes this is an
old idea that got learned in the 20s and
most everyone has forgotten but the fact
is when you have a long period of mal
distributing incomes that is the folks
at the top get a larger share and
everybody else gets a smaller share
eventually it erodes the strength of
your economy I think that's what's
happened in the last couple of years for
the Fed i would say you've got to invent
a system of coordination and
accountability and the best most direct
solution for that is to simply declare
that the Federal Reserve is a sub-agency
of the Treasury Department make the
president responsible for it bring it
out into the open let's let's debate
about these things I'm not sure that any
of what I've just said is going to
happen the book is secrets of the temple
published by simon and schuster 1987 on
bookshelves in time for the season the
author William grider a national editor
at rolling stone also wrote at the
education of david stockman and others
like to thank you for being with us
thank you